y el bate bola encarna la cultura de los
suburbios
cada año este grupo carnavalesco desfile
en campo grande el barrio más populoso
del río de janeiro y también el más
castigado por el coronavirus todo
empieza en este taller meses antes del
carnaval la confección de los disfraces
es un trabajo artesanal realizado con
esmero y cariño
alguien si mienta pintamos primero los
colores escogidos del dibujo que está
hecho en el ordenador y después
colocamos la purpurina del mismo color
preferimos hacer nuestro traje a mano
porque queda más trabajado y tiene un
aspecto mejor
el vate bora es como una pequeña escuela
de samba todos los años estrena un tema
una canción y una ropa diferente
el ideal es la alegría del barrio tanto
que cada barrio tiene su propio estilo
de bate bola
y el bate voy al gigante el de cappa el
de botas el bate bola en río de janeiro
representa el carnaval callejero ianiero
y hippies cerca la bordiú la pandemia
robo el carnaval a los cariocas
[Aplausos]
piscina y asado solo un pequeño consuelo
pero familia no se resigna su batidora
saldrá aunque inversión reducida
hicimos unos disfraces más simples y
festejamos en un local privado para que
la policía no decomisen nuestros
disfraces además sería errado desfilar
la bola es el emblema de este personaje
hace tiempo que el plástico reemplazó
las tradicionales vejigas de buey pero
el ruido sigue potente
otros grupos debate bolas resolvieron
arriesgarse a pesar del veto municipal
en un impulso de última hora devolvieron
a las calles la magia del carnaval en un
desfile corto y clandestino